waiting for fuel so much frustration
especially towards anyone who tries to
jump the queue
there isn't enough petrol in sri lanka
the government has run out of money my
age is 25 i'm waiting here 15 days
you're losing your life yeah
you say enjoy life no
are you angry
too much
why we don't have any tea also lunch
dinner breakfast nobody here
unable to afford even the basics sri
lankans grow poorer
hit with an economic crisis so severe
the country and its people are destitute
vitamin calcium
three months pregnant nashandini is
feeling weak and doctors are worried the
family can't afford to buy enough fruit
and vegetables to keep her unborn baby
healthy
how does it feel
when you can't afford to provide for
your family
now the country has an acting president
reynold wick remasinga sworn into the
job after the former president gotta
buyer rajapaksa resigned
months of protests forced the country's
top leaders to quit
sri lankans have transformed the
political landscape of this country but
they have little control over its
economic future the rajapaksas have left
it bankrupt and crippled with debt
the damage done to the economy will take
years to recover
but after months of struggle
sri lankans have at least taken control
of their future
nicole johnston
sky news colombo